la primera noción de ácidos y bases se
debe a este caballero de aquí que se
llama svante arrhenius quien por cierto
fue el tercer químico en obtener un
premio nobel en 1903 y bueno su
definición de ácido
ha sido nos dice que un nacido es una
cosa que incrementa la cantidad de
protones si se coloca en una solución la
cosa no crear y los ácidos incrementan
incrementen la concentración la
concentración de protones de hidrógeno
podemos simplemente poner aquí ya firmes
h más es simplemente un protón ok pero
tones cuando se colocan en una solución
acuosa se coloquen en una solución
acuosa y ahora pues nos podemos imaginar
cuál sería la definición de una base tal
vez podríamos pensar que una base es
algo que hace que haya menos protones no
creo que haya un decrecimiento aunque
sabes que no mejor hay que decirlo de
otra forma mejor vamos a decir que una
base es algo que incrementa la
concentración de hidróxido una base
incrementa
incrementa la concentración
concentración de iones hidróxido cuando
cuando se coloca en una solución acuosa
coloque a en una solución acuosa y ahora
vamos a ver unos cuantos ejemplos
entonces saber un ácido de arrhenius
fuerte que bueno por cierto también va a
ser un ácido fuerte con respecto a otras
definiciones de ácidos pero un ácido de
rinus fuerte es el ácido clorhídrico así
es que tenemos por aquí nuestro ácido
clorhídrico que es un hidrógeno y cloro
si tenemos nuestro ácido clorhídrico y
lo ponemos en una solución acuosa el
ácido clorhídrico se va a disociar y de
hecho se va a disociar muy rápido porque
esta reacción está muy favorecida de
izquierda a derecha aunque hay es una
reacción que tiende a irse rápidamente
de izquierda a derecha por aquí tenemos
un enlace entre este hidrógeno y este
cloro y el cloro se va a llevar los dos
electrones de este enlace covalente
dejando al hidrógeno sin ni un solo
electrón así es que el hidrógeno se va a
quedar como
un protón de hidrógeno solito y el cloro
por aquí está el cloro se va a quedar
con todos los electrones que ya tenía
más ese electrón que le acaba de robar
al hidrógeno entonces ahora tiene una
carga negativa y bueno los dos siguen
estando disueltos en una solución acuosa
a cosa entonces justo en este momento se
puede ver la definición de ácido de
arrhenius porque aquí si ponemos el
ácido clorhídrico en una solución acuosa
el ácido clorhídrico se disocia y por lo
tanto incrementa la cantidad de protones
acabe la cantidad de iones de hidrógeno
en la solución y bueno ya hemos hablado
de esto anteriormente muchas veces vas a
ver estas reacciones escritas de esta
forma pero pues los protones de
hidrógeno no se quedan sentados así nada
más en el agua
estos protones de hidrógeno van a ir y
hacer enlaces con el agua no quería
formar moléculas de hidrógeno
entonces otra forma en la que te vas a
encontrar a esta reacción es de esta
otra forma vamos a escribirla por aquí
tenemos el ácido clorhídrico en una
solución acuosa y esto es simplemente
una forma más elegante de decir que está
disuelto en agua y después tenemos
nuestras moléculas de agua que son h
y vas a ver en muchísimos lados que
denotan que el agua se encuentra en su
estado líquido de esta forma y esta
reacción nos va a dar sólo que aquí en
lugar de poner un protón de hidrógeno
vamos a decir ok si se disocia el ácido
clorhídrico tenemos protones por ahí
pero el protón de hidrógeno va a ser un
enlace con el oxígeno del agua y
entonces vamos a obtener h3o ahora esta
cosa
originalmente era una molécula de agua y
únicamente obtuvo un protón de hidrógeno
sin electrón entonces ahora esto va a
tener una carga positiva y bueno estas
moléculas siguen estando en una solución
acuosa y también tenemos este ión
cloruro ión cloruro con su carga
negativa que por cierto como es un guión
y tiene una carga negativa entonces le
llamamos àngel así es que este es un
cañón cloruro que también se encuentra
en esta solución acuosa
todo esto está disuelto en agua y
recordemos qué es lo que sucedió por
aquí teníamos ácido clorhídrico pero a
la hora de entrar en una solución acuosa
el cloro se quedó con todos los
electrones de este enlace dejando al
hidrógeno como un solo protón sin ningún
electrón y el protón hizo un enlace con
una molécula de agua formando hidronew
entonces y ahora viene una pregunta
viendo esta reacción todavía podemos
decir pensando en la definición que
aumenta la cantidad de protones de
hidrógeno lo que definitivamente sí
podríamos decir es que incrementan la
cantidad de hidrógeno aumenta la
cantidad de iones y drones y bueno esto
con respecto a la definición de 'harry
nos nos dice que el ácido clorhídrico es
un ácido de arrhenius fuerte que hay el
ácido clorhídrico es un ácido fuerte
ahora que sería una base fuerte de
acuerdo con la definición de ácidos y
bases de riñón pues una base muy fuerte
que conocemos es el hidróxido de sodio
que tenemos por aquí sodio
hidróxido pero el hidróxido lo que es es
un oxígeno enlazado con un hidrógeno
ahora si quieres ver cómo se ve el
hidróxido de sodio nos podemos ir por
acá en el hidróxido de sodio lo que
tenemos es un oxígeno que tiene un
enlace covalente con un hidrógeno y este
oxígeno tiene tres pares de electrones
libres ok
porque este oxígeno se quedó con un
electrón de algún otro átomo en algún
otro momento así es que además tiene una
carga negativa y por otro lado pero muy
cerca tenemos al sodio que perdió alguno
de sus electrones con algún otro átomo y
entonces tiene una carga positiva y de
hecho no sabemos pero incluso hasta pudo
haber perdido su electrón dejándoselo a
este oxígeno de aquí y entonces este
oxígeno tiene una carga negativa y este
sodio tiene una carga positiva por lo
tanto hay mucha atracción entre estos
dos átomos estos dos átomos están muy
atraídos
uno al otro y así forman un enlace
iónico porque el sodio tiene una carga
positiva y el hidróxido de hecho tiene
una carga negativa y esa atracción entre
cargas opuestas es lo que los mantiene
unidos pero bueno pones el hidróxido de
sodio en una solución acuosa y esta
molécula se va a disociar y además se va
a disociar en sodio el guión de sodio
con carga positiva que sigue estando en
una solución acuosa y por otro lado
vamos a tener el hidróxido o keith con
su carga negativa que también está en
una solución acuosa entonces tomamos
hidróxido de sodio lo ponemos en una
solución acuosa y se disocia en sodio e
hidróxido estos dos simplemente se
separan y por lo tanto si ponemos
hidróxido de sodio en una solución
acuosa aumentamos la concentración de
hidróxido
si es que de acuerdo a la definición de
base de arrhenius el hidróxido de sodio
es una base de arrhenius fuerte morey es
una base fuerte
en este momento yo te recomiendo que
veas las otras definiciones de ácido
base que veas la definición de lewis y
de bronze de lori y que pienses acerca
de cómo se categorizan estas moléculas